le 11 septembre
je prenais l'avion pour le caire
cela faisait de nombreuses années que je
souhaitais aller en egypte et lorsque
l'opportunité s'est présentée j'ai sauté
sur l'occasion
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je pense
j'ai grandi avec l'image d'une égypte
symbole de mystère le plus grand mystère
étant évidemment celui des pyramides
supposé renfermer de grand secret et
dont on ignorait toujours comment elles
ont été construites pourtant jusqu'à
l'âge adulte l'egypte n'exerça pas sur
moi une fascination particulière sans
doute parce que les théories que
j'entendais à son propos me paraissait
trop farfelue ou contradictoires pour
que je daigne consacré mon attention mon
attrait pour l'egypte est venue plus
tard quand j'ai commencé à étudier la
philosophie à l'université et que j'ai
découvert que certains textes faisait de
l'egypte une terre de connaissance
ancestrale dont les grecs eux mêmes
s'étaient inspirés pour bâtir leur
philosophie
j'appris que platon avait séjourné en
egypte pour y recevoir l'enseignement
des prêtres et qu'ils avaient été
précédés dans cette démarche par thales
et pythagore qui aurait rapporté
l'egypte les théorèmes mathématiques qui
porte leur nom j'ai alors commencé à
prendre l'egypte au sérieux sortant
progressivement de la représentation des
anciens égyptiens comme d'un peuple
enfants vénérant des dieux à tête
d'animaux en approfondissant mes
recherches je me suis rendu compte que
la mythologie égyptienne n'était pas un
récit fantastique mais une fresque
philosophique selon l'idée dont
s'inspira la fontaine on transmet mieux
la connaissance par des fables que par
les discours ennuyeux
plus j'approfondis c'est ma connaissance
de la culture égyptienne plus grand dit
c'est mon désir de partir à la rencontre
des monuments sur lesquels sa
philosophie est inscrite lorsqu'un de
mes amis me proposa de l'accompagner en
egypte pour un voyage d'une semaine je
n'ai pas hésité une seconde et c'est
ainsi que j'ai pris l'avion direction la
terre des pharaons afin de voir de plus
près ce que l'egypte a à nous révéler
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
ce n'est pas été déçus du voyage
avant de vous livrer mes impressions sur
mon séjour en egypte je voudrais vous
présenter les deux personnes qui m'ont
permis de réaliser ce voyage est acquis
je voudrais faire un peu de publicité
mohamed salem propriétaire du bateau le
roi à bord duquel j'ai navigué sur le
nil et benjamin vernet organisateurs de
voyages pour l' agence boss voyage basée
en france je vous parlerai également de
sheryfa del sale est notre guide
originaire d'alexandrie un passionné qui
connaît aussi bien l'histoire de son
pays que l'histoire de france
arrivé au caire j'ai pris un avion pour
louxor où nous attendait le bateau de
mohamed nous avons navigué vers à soie
an pendant sept jours durant lesquels
nous à marion quotidiennement pour
visiter les sites antiques à proximité
le premier jour j'ai visité le temple de
karnak dédié au dieu amon et autres fois
relié au temple de louxor par une allée
des sphinx de 3 km actuellement en cours
de réaménagement
ce qui frappe immédiatement quand on
arrive à carnac c'est la hauteur
impressionnante jusqu'à laquelle la
pierre s'élève face à l'obélisque
d'hatchepsout tu de 30 mètres de haut
pour un poids de 325 tonnes on se
transpose forcément dans les conditions
de l'époque pour imaginer comment ils
sont bien pu s'y prendre pour l'ériger
la deuxième chose qui saisit le visiteur
en egypte c'est le foisonnement des
détails et l'impossibilité de s'arrêter
sur chacun d'entre eux et qui fait qu'on
passe son temps à tourner les yeux
autour de soi avec l'espoir naïf de
réussir à tout voir on parle d'un des
endroits les plus anciens façonné par la
main de l'homme un endroit dont chaque
centimètre carré et gorgées d'une
histoire qui se content millénaire mon
réflexe premier a donc été de marché et
de marché encore afin de ne pas perdre
une miette de tout ce qu'il y avait à
voir mon smartphone m'informa que
j'avais atteint les dix mille pas avant
la fin de la matinée à titre informatif
la surface du temple de karnak est
d'environ deux kilomètres carrés soit
l'équivalent d'un rectangle d'un
kilomètre sur deux autant vous dire que
si on veut tout voir il ne faut pas
traîner
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai compris
que mon approche n'était pas la bonne et
que pour visiter ces temples il ne
fallait pas se ruer sur chaque détail
mais au contraire prendre du recul
regardez depuis suffisamment loin pour
que l'observation deviennent
contemplation
car c'est là que la grandeur de ses
monuments se révèle à nos yeux
le deuxième jour je pénétrai dans la
vallée des rois
la vallée des rois est une nécropole
située dans le désert et abritant
plusieurs tombeau de pharaon de l'époque
du nouvel empire c'est un lieu
particulièrement aride entouré de
falaises qui nous donnerait presque
l'impression d'avoir été taillés dans la
roche tout comme la montagne en forme de
pyramide qui surplombe la vallée
même si ce lieu mérite qu'on s'y arrête
pour le contempler ici on est davantage
portée à observer les détails qui
composent ces tombeaux des tombeaux
auquel on accède par de longs couloirs
parsemé de peintures aux couleurs encore
vives qui décrivent avec précision le
voyage de l'âme du pharaon dans l'au
delà
à chaque étape de mon voyage j'ai été
traversée par ce tiraillement entre
grandeur et détails comme je le fus au
temple d'edfou dédié à horus dont chérif
nous appris qu'il avait été construit
sur les ruines d'un temple plus anciens
ce qui augmente encore si besoin en
était ma frustration de ne pas savoir ce
qui s'y trouvaient avant
plus on s'approche physiquement des
grands monuments de la civilisation
égyptienne plus on prend conscience de
l'étendue de ce qu'on ignore sur eux
aller en egypte
ce n'est pas trouvé la réponse à ces
énigmes c'est se rendre compte à quel
point ces énigmes sont impénétrables
d'une manière générale les temples
égyptiens ont cette capacité de nous
faire nous sentir petit les gratte ciel
de new york ou de dubaï font pâle figure
à côté des pyramides de gizeh qui
lorsqu'on les voit nous font prendre la
mesure de la phrase de napoléon quand il
disait à ses soldats du haut de ces
pyramides quarante siècles vous
contemplent
c'est quelque chose que j'ai
particulièrement ressenti dans le temple
de louxor que j'ai eu la chance de
visiter au crépuscule avant que la nuit
ne tombe et que les lumières ne viennent
sublimer la pierre j'observais le
contraste entre ces groupes de touristes
fourmillant dans l'enceinte du temple
pour apporter quelques photos dont je
faisais partie et cet édifice
plurimillénaire et silencieux semblant
imperméable à l'agitation des modernes
j'avais sous les yeux l'illustration
archétypale de l'opposition entre les
grandes choses fixe et les petites
choses en mouvement comme si finalement
nous n'étions pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils nous ont légué
au bout de quelques jours on peut pas
vraiment dire qu'on se soit habitué à la
grandeur et à la précision des monuments
car plus on en découvre plus on prend
conscience de la constance des efforts
dans le temps qu'il a fallu aux anciens
égyptiens pour les bâtir
louxor et karnak est fou pilar et sans
parler de guizeh
c'est à la fin de mon voyage d'une
semaine en egypte à abou simbel que j'ai
vécu une expérience connu sous le nom de
syndrome de stendhal il s'agit d'une
réaction du corps du à la contemplation
d'une oeuvre qui nous touche
particulièrement en arrivant à abou
simbel je ne m'attendais pas à découvrir
ce que cette pauline degré cash à la vue
des arrivants alors que j'étais en train
de régler ma caméra j'ai levé les yeux
et me suis retrouvé nez à nez avec les
quatre statues géantes de ramsès ii qui
surmonte l'entrée du temple j'ai été
physiquement stupéfait comme si ça ne
suffisait pas chérif nous expliqua que
chaque année le 22 février et le 22
octobre les rayons du soleil viennent
illuminer la statue de ramsès située au
fond du temple ce qui selon les
historiens aurait été volontaire de la
part des égyptiens pour signifier le
jour de la naissance et celui du
couronnement de l'ancien pharaons
je repartais d'égypte comme je serais
reparti d'ayn rand de boxe
sonnée mais avec la ferme envie d'y
retourner d'y retourner pour voir ce
qu'on peut voir la première fois tu y
retourner pour joindre à l'oeil du corps
l'oeil de l'esprit car si aristote a
raison de dire que la pensée et la fille
de l'étonnement nul doute que mon séjour
en egypte m'aura donné
matière à penser
[Musique]
comme annoncé je vais maintenant faire
un peu de publicité aux deux personnes
qui m'ont permis de réaliser ce voyage
voici benjamin de lagence boss voyage à
qui j'ai demandé pourquoi selon lui il
fallait visiter l'egypte l'egypte est un
pays qui renferme énormément de mystère
d'une part et même depuis qu'on est
petit qu'on étudiait l'école on a envie
en fait dans sa vie un petit peu plus
les mystères de les découvrir par ses
yeux propres l'autre raison est aussi le
côté monumental la civilisation
égyptienne a laissé énormément de traces
qui ont survécu jusqu'à aujourd'hui tu
as pu le voir avec moi lors de notre
voyage et j'ai toujours été subjugués de
voir ces témoignages historiques de
civilisation des civilisations
constructrice qui ont traversé les âges
et essayer de m'imaginer parfois sur
place comment était la vie à cette
époque là quelles sont les raisons qui
ont poussé ces peuples à ériger de tel
de tels monuments les monuments
égyptiens le temple de karnak notamment
où le site d'abou simbel non beaucoup
plus frappés que certains autres titres
que j'ai pu découvrir lors d'autres
prêts d'autres voyages dans de
précédents pays où ces coûts y avait
aussi quand même noté culturel certains
ont fait de sion le constructeur de
voyage je vais aller sélectionner des
étapes pour des clients des itinéraires
les montées de façon logique ou
éventuellement des sites un petit peu
secret les gens s'arrêtent pas forcément
parfois et donc j'essaie d'apporter ce
savoir et mes connaissances aux gens qui
nous sollicitent pour ceux d'entre vous
qui voudraient effectuer ce même voyage
je vous laisse les coordonnées de
benjamin dans la description
voici mohamed propriétaire du bateau le
roi sur lequel j'ai passé plusieurs
jours à naviguer sur le nil entre louxor
et assouan pour le remercier de son
invitation sur son bateau je lui laisse
la parole pour nous présenter son
activité et son rôle de médiateur
culturel
nous sommes à bord du navire wars
naviguons entre louxor et assouan l'idée
du droit c'est de maintenir une
navigation agréable et de profiter au
maximum s'est ouverte vers l'extérieur
comme vous pouvez le voir nous avons la
chance d'avoir des paysages mais
linéaire sur une île et ses paysages de
là nous on est amoureux un peu c'est
notre passion on essaye de faire
découvrir l'égypte avec cette façade là
une façade tranquille une façade de
qualité une façade d'un voyage
inoubliable je lui dis toujours avait à
certains de nos voyageurs nous sommes
des créateurs de souvenirs d'avis roi
c'est pas le type de bateau où on a une
soirée danse du ventre le soir mais vous
avez une conférence on développe si vous
voulez ce tourisme loin de la masse et
au même temps un tourisme responsable
moi je veux aussi responsabilités nous
avons ici à bord vingt-trois personnes
qui travaillent au sein ce client
maximum tous de louxor et verront ce
sont des natifs de la région qui vivent
là des moments avec nos voyageurs et qui
font découvrir aussi le pays la région
l'image clés qu'on essaie de donner de
l'abbaye roi et du programme de droit
profiter au maximum des visites et des
paysages du nil dans la journée y'a pas
mieux que de faire visiter un pays en
prenant le temps est là avec le dernier
roi est le programme que nous avons on
arrive à prendre le temps et à mieux
découvrir un bis origine merci moi même
et au plaisir de te revoir en egypte
j'espère que ce bref carnet de voyage en
egypte aura éveillé votre désir d'en
savoir plus sur les fondements de cette
civilisation
et pourquoi pas de vous rendre sur place
pour vivre cette expérience
car la flamme de l'esprit revient
toujours vivifier d'un séjour sur la
terre des énigmes
[Musique]